desafiando las gélidas temperaturas y
las largas esperas en los puestos
fronterizos con los incesantes ataques
de las tropas del kremlin miles de
ucranianos se apresuran a salir de
ucrania
out of pain siento mucho dolor y pena
solo dolor mucho dolor por mi país y mi
gente no tenemos palabras para explicar
este dolor
que dejaste atrás
mi casa mi marido mi perro mis gatos mi
vida
en quien muchos esperan para poder
subirse en alguno de los trenes de las
abarrotadas de estaciones para otras
familias como la de olga dejar ucraniano
es una opción entender resguardarse de
los bombardeos rusos en el interior de
las estaciones del metro de la capital
más de 15.000 personas se esconden allí
según las autoridades locales
tenemos miedo de salir de kiev porque vi
con mis ojos son autobuses civiles al
que dispararon he visto coches quemados
he oído que han disparado a coches
civiles con familias y niños en tan sólo
una semana más de 874 mil personas han
oído de ucrania según acnur ucrania está
a punto de situarse en el top 5 de
países con mayor número de refugiados la
mayoría son mujeres y niños
haremos todo lo posible para llevar
ayuda para acoger los ucranianos de
forma digna para acoger a los europeos a
los miembros de la unión europea que
están regresando pero también asegurarse
de que las personas que vienen de fuera
de europa puedan ser bienvenidas y
puedan regresar de manera segura donde
quieren ir
la comisión europea propuso ofrecer
protección temporal estos refugiados lo
que les daría derechos básicos a la
vivienda salud y empleo y las naciones
del bloque europeo continúan gestionando
la acogida de los granos